hi in this video i'm going to talk about
gel filtration chromatography or gfc so
gfc is a very important method for
protein purification
so the separation principle is based on
that
separation basis basis is basically on
size and shape of that macromolecule so
protein would be separated on base of
their size
and base of on basis of their shape
so the principle is like that protein
having larger size
would not enter the particular pores of
gel bead used in this chromatography and
protein with smaller size would enter
the gel beads and would be [ __ ] so
protein with higher molecular weight or
protein with greater size
would uh eluted first so it's a column
chromatography so let's see step by step
how this uh gel filtration
chromatography works
so it's a column chromatography as you
can see there is a particular column
and in this column there are a lot of
circular beads
porous beads
and these
porous beads have definite function in
this particular gel filtration
chromatography
and
if we zoom inside these porous beads we
would find that
the small molecules here depicted in
blue can easily get inside the pores of
this bead
and if they get inside the pore of that
bead they would be [ __ ]
in contrast the
big red molecules or red proteins
whatever you might think
these red proteins
would not enter the bead because they
are
too large to get in into the bead
so they would uh
say from the side space they would get
eluted and they would be eluted first
so there is a exclusion limit the
smallest size
by which
the protein or the macromolecule can
enter the bid it's called the exclusion
limit of that particular gel bead
and we would see these exclusion limit
in a moment
and back to our main diagram
so first step would be equilibration
equilibration means we would apply the
buffer and we would
allow the buffer to
run through this
gel to this from this column and after
that second step would be sample
application so we put our sample in our
sample we have our red protein which has
the biggest size then a green protein
and the smallest blue protein so it's a
mixed sample and now we want to
just separate this red green and blue
protein from each other now let's see
what happens after we load the sample
when we load the sample the red proteins
as they are biggest they would
get through these matrix but they won't
enter these gel beads
and
as you can see in this second step
they are getting through these
small pores in the matrix
but they are not entering the gel where
whereas the small blue molecules as they
are small
their size are small
so they can enter these gel beads and
thus they get [ __ ] so that is why
first
the red
proteins or red macromolecules are
eluted then the green one and at the
last the blue ones are eluted so as you
can see in this step wash step we would
be using washing buffer and the red
protein as they have greater size bigger
size
they would be eluted first whereas the
green protein would be eluted next and
at last the blue protein would be eluded
so let's see some popular gel beads
so we have bio gel p that is actually
polyacrylamide based gel and its
exclusion limit is 0.2 to 400 kilodalton
that means
uh if a
protein or a macromolecule which have a
molecular weight
within this limit can enter the gel bead
and we can have also sepharose or bio
gel a
which has
which are agarose based bio gel a that
has the highest exclusion limit so if
you want to purify large proteins then
we would choose these sepharose instead
of bio gel p or cephalics cephadex is
actually dextron based and its exclusion
limit is slightly higher than bio gel p
but a lot more lower than
severals so its uh exclusion limit is
point seven to six hundred kilo dalton
and
now we would talk about
few volumes and how we can predict the
molecular weight from these gel
filtration chromatography
so we have some
volumes here
so total volume would be equal to void
volume plus internal volume plus bed
volume now what is void volume so void
volume are these spaces
so these spaces in uh between two bits
so if we just zoom in this picture
the volume over here i am
shading it in red
would be the void volume
so this is depicted as v
0 or void volume the internal volume is
the volume inside the gel beads
so whatever the volume is inside the gel
bead it is actually internal volume and
the bed volume the total volume occupied
by these gel matrix is actually the bed
volume
so the sum of all volume would give us
the total volume
now
the x we have to understand another
equation that is
volume of illusion that means the amount
of buffer we are giving to elude our
particular protein is actually equal to
void volume plus
sigma times
internal volume
where this sigma is actually partition
coefficient of the particular solute and
here in this case the solute would be
protein
and
this partition coefficient is very
important to calculate the molecular
mass
so if we have say say we have
a lot of non-molecular weight proteins
and
we calculated their
partition coefficient
and what we can do next that we can plot
their partition coefficient and
molecular mass and there would be a
linear relation between their molecular
mass and the partition coefficient and
from that standard curve we can actually
find out
uh the partition coefficient for our
unknown protein and
by which we can actually
use it and extrapolate that so if we
know the partition coefficient for for
our unknown protein and now we can
actually extrapolate that graph to find
the molecular mass of that particular
protein
so in this respect in this
by this method we can actually
predict the molecular rough molecular
mass of that particular protein
and
this is how gel filtration
chromatography is very important so just
to summarize the basic concepts behind
gel filtration chromatography so what we
have in the separation principle we have
the separation is on the basis of size
and shape of our protein and we can
predict the
rough molecular mass of that protein and
other thing we have to remember for this
gel filtration chromatography is that
the proteins that have larger shape
larger size and shape would not enter
the gel beads and would be eluted first
and rapidly
and the proteins which have small size
would enter the jail and thus get
[ __ ] and they would be eluted at
last
so as in our
situation the red protein has
bigger shape so it had it had been
eluted first then the green protein and
at last the blue proteins are eluted
because the blue protein has smaller
size
and that's all about gel filtration
chromatography hope you enjoyed the
video please like and subscribe thank
you